Involvement I'll
ask you again,
who are you?
By the time Oyatsu turns 16, we need to
be the strongest in the country, let alone the continent. There will
definitely come a time when we will need Cain's power.
[Music]
I will be reincarnated.  Would you lose everything if someone found out?
But these people have been waiting for you to come. It's a
simple von Silford or some other number. From
today onwards, I'm going to ask for your help.
[Music] You look
great in your uniform. There's a lot going on this year.
There were some students who weren't part of the plan, so I came all the way to say hello.Welcome
to the Art Guild Headquarters, which is riveted by mystery.If I hadn't stopped you, the floor here would have been
stained with blood by now.If you drank more than me, it would be your
blood.  The floor will be stained, but I understand.
I'm going to marry you.
[Music] Please
explain in detail. That's not true.
[Music]